don't we've known you for I think what
ten years yes okay long time and I know
you you've come up with some great
analogies which I would love to go into
later I know you talked about the red
carpet producer which I still love that
that term anyway but one thing I want to
ask you about is and I heard you say it
somewhere else you said being in
Hollywood and staying here for a length
of time will not maybe change you but
it'll just make you more of what you
already are yeah okay well that was the
advice that was given to me many years
ago before I moved out here by a person
that worked in Hollywood with Jerry
Bruckheimer and he said John you you
want to take a really good stock of
yourself here now because everything
that you do here everything that you
think everything that you believe
everything that you indulge in good or
bad it will be available to you out here
at a much greater level and degree and
things that you don't even know about
wool are abundant you said you will
become more of who you are rather than
it changing you you'll actually be able
to fulfill all of those things that are
both inside of you and how you feel and
the way you see the world and the kind
of friends that you hang out with and
things that you go and do in your spare
time and so I took that to heart I
didn't understand it other than the you
know observable okay he's telling me to
think about myself and think about Who I
am deeply I wasn't worried in that
regard but in my 18 years out here I
would say that that statement is still
very true today not just for myself but
for any of us I think it's it's
Hollywood affords you a lot of things
not just the film industry but Los
Angeles its abundant its abundant
everywhere you want to go there are
several Starbucks within walking
distance there are multiple places and
things that you can do and there's also
a variety of people that maybe in your
small town there were only one or two
there are now dozens if not hundreds
and a lot of them have money so you know
taking that into perspective and and
looking at these last several years
growth it can challenge you to and the
only answer that I have for that is
really to look deeper within yourself
and some of those things that you have
to look deeper within can be painful
they can cause you to feel disappointed
about when you don't get what you want
when you create something that is not
received well when you when you don't
win the approval of certain people that
you maybe want to work with or have
access to or get to quote the next level
but fundamentally I think what it
teaches you that discipline of
introspection is one where you become
more fulfilled and happy because of what
you are actually doing that is true to
yourself as opposed to trying to worry
about what others outside expect of you
you have to start with your own internal
expectations and those things may evolve
but they they can only evolve because of
you not because of someone else giving
you an opportunity or not or someone
else approving of you or not ultimately
at the end of day how you feel about
yourself is is a person that's up in
here and what's in here and that
personal commitment was the one that I
found in my journey to go through
Hollywood which was who is really Who am
I Who am I truly inside and what do I
really believe about this world looking
at things with new eyes being critical
of myself not to the point where you put
yourself down
I think that's an external issue but
really one where you go okay what do I
want to do with my life what are the
things that I believe about this world
do I believe in the bad things about
do I also believe in the beauty of the
world and what holds it all together and
how am I gonna grow up and how do I
affect through art what I see and know
to be true and give something to that
that inspires how I feel in me to others
and so it comes from a personal place
where we all have journeys as artists
we're sensitive we're very open people
but there is a I guess you could say if
you're going to use that sensitivity to
tell stories or say things do it
truthfully do it through the vehicle of
art and your personal commitment is one
that is an evolution in yourself so what
I knew 10 years ago and what I know
today is very different but that doesn't
mean that what I knew 10 years ago was
wrong it's just all I was able to do at
the time what I was capable of and so
drawing from those experiences those
hardships even the times where you feel
really down you know maybe even
depressed in some cases is not always at
the time that you see that as a real
opportunity but it is in those moments
that you're challenged the most that
shows you not only what you're capable
of but what you're also really good at
because you don't have everything going
for you the way you expected it to or
hope to or wanted it to and so you have
to dig deeper but if you're deep
you're digging deep is to blame or
attack or get frustrated and say you
know these people over here causing me
to you know what they don't know you I
mean they can do whatever they want to
do but it's about yourself and the
journey through that process of becoming
your truest self is the one that gives
you the greatest success at least I
believe that because looking back
between where I started on one our
fantasy girl to now a child's voice and
six movies later in ten years
I am so grateful for that process
because it had its ups and downs and the
only way that I can measure it is that
I'm happier than I ever have been in my
entire life and I want to keep getting
happier and I want to keep doing stories
that are not talked about I want to do
things that help inspire the good in
people because it inspires the good in
me
so the truest part of those statements
about people who are you know that it
doesn't change you it's really that you
do fulfill more of who you are if you
allow yourself to commit to that rather
than trying to chase after things and
make it so that you know somebody in
Hollywood will quote pay attention to
your work but really go out there for
the reason that you want to you want to
touch audiences you want to touch people
I also said some years ago I didn't
really understand at the time I think it
was more because of the digital world
that we were emerging in 10 years ago
after the financial crash and how
everything was going digital and online
obviously it's played itself out quite
well it's still evolving but I said
something that Hollywood is not the
audience it never has been and I would
say that irregardless of what Hollywood
does as an industry in its executives
and and all of those things I think
there are really great people working in
there I have no doubt that there are
people that really want to make a
difference and do good things in their
work but at the same time chasing after
those those agendas and and modelling
yourself after them I think really in
art you can become bold and unique and
different and stand out and the only way
I see people doing that is by commitment
full commitment to the belief in what
they're doing such the point that
it's not an issue for them about who's
getting involved and not they're
determined to make the film at whatever
level they have to do it with the
capacity and the capabilities that
they're they're not waiting out for
somebody else to come in there and and
and you know just say it's okay we got
you everything's fine now it's really
more so what's up in here and in here
and trying to create that vision and
align people who feel the same way you
do are joining you on this journey and
going through it because there's a
commitment from within them and I think
as a producer there is a responsibility
there to set that kind of tone which is
not an authoritarian one it's one of of
your own self and attracting those kinds
of people and that's how we've been able
to do the movies that we've done because
we didn't have big funders we we did
crowd-sourced we did our own personal
funds we brought other people into the
mix that were kind of like silent
investors they just wanted us to do well
and I can't wait for what we do next
really can
you